the other thing that troubled me deeply
was that you know my students they
really love me they come back they
volunteer they get extra credit for
their High School classes their middle
school classes
and some of my boys came back
telling me that there were girls who
were in the shower room at the middle
school
and looking at them
and
so I inquired are there girls in the a
parent came to me and asked me to
inquire for them are there girls in the
boy's bathroom and the administration
said no
and so uh the parents
pushed on it and it turns out of course
that there there were girls in the boys
bathroom showering and undressing
it's just that
they're not called girls they're called
boys because they you know they say I
identify as a boy and if you don't enter
that delusional world
again you'll be
you'll be um disciplined
I'm Dave Rubin and joining me today is
an award-winning california-based fifth
grade teacher who was suspended for from
his job for believing in two genders Ray
Shelton welcome to the Reuben report
well thank you for having me it's nice
to be here Ray I have to say technically
I guess this isn't your first appearance
on the Reuben report because uh much of
my audience will remember this clip that
we're going to throw to right now a
couple weeks back you were on Dr Phil
talking about gender sexuality what
should and shouldn't be taught in
schools biological reality and all of
that good stuff let's get right to it
transgender boys who might not have
their own money to go buy tampons if
they're provided free in the bathroom
it's it's a huge plus men do not
menstruate only women menstrate now you
can call yourself whatever you want
right but trans men do menstrual
non-binary people menstrating is not
exclusive yes it's women no it's not yes
it is
if your Columbus homes are XX and you're
young you menstruate if you're XY you
don't correct but what about trans men
and non-violence we're not shooting a
whole group they're women dressed as men
you are not a man you pretend to be a
man and that's okay that's perfectly
fine live your life tell me what a man
is well what's a man to you you define a
man for me you have chromosomes that are
X and Y that's what a man is so why are
we just looking at the the the the
science of this as an assignment when
when we've learned sex and gender
identity a two very the completely
different things
they are completely different completely
different words
and sex is what you're born with the
sexual reproductive organs you have
gender is what you identify with well I
don't accept that distinction you have
to argue for it you're just giving a
conclusion you're you're just making it
up people the people who hate the truth
people who hate the truth or because
they see they see the truth as hateful
if you want to identify in any way you
can you're free to do so but that does
not mean that the rest of us have to
join that illusion Ray tell me a little
bit before we introduce the the other
fine gentleman here uh tell me a little
bit about what you were expecting when
you accepted doing that show uh did they
reach out to you and say hey you're
going to be on the opposite side of some
of these activists I mean how did this
all come to pass
well
getting on the Dr Phil show is actually
somewhat of a complicated story that
particular episode that aired on
Thursday the 20th I believe of April
was actually taped a year ago
wow I yeah I was invited
as a support member to a guest
who was
discussing the fact that her daughter
had been lured into believing her
teenage daughter was lured into
believing that she was
actually a boy through social media and
her the school hid that from the mother
and so this was the mother's story of
getting her daughter back and because I
was a public school teacher
they invited me to sort of back her up
because when you're a guest on the Phil
show
they let you bring three or four people
just you know so you don't feel so alone
so they taped the first episode and I
spoke for maybe 60 Seconds
I just said something to the effect of
um
these are not my Stu children these are
I'm a caretaker as a as a teacher and
it's inappropriate for me to be
discussing uh issues of human sexuality
and gender at the elementary level which
is which is what I teach
so at the end of the taping
uh Dr Phil decided he said this is this
is good this is good material let's tape
a second episode
right now if we would agree to it and I
think he wanted something a little
spicier because as soon as we started
taping the second show
he immediately brought me in
to to speak up more because the other
guests were ladies and they were very
polite and you know they weren't as
direct as I had been previously so
the the second part the clip that you
just showed actually he just kept it in
the can for almost a year that's
interesting I mean welcome to Showbiz
man that's how it works you know that
you do something decent next thing you
know they're throwing you back on and
taping another show before we go any
further there is another box here and uh
this gentleman is either your cattle
rancher or your lawyer help me out who
is this guy and let's let him say hello
this is a great guy this is my lawyer
I'm going to let him introduce himself
he is fantastic and uh I'm glad he's I'm
glad he's uh taking the lean on this
yeah great David tell me how you got in
the mix here yeah I'm just here you know
when I'm not representing Ray in his
legal case um I just uh show the horse
manure at his Ranch but but actually
yeah so why does why does an elementary
school teacher who's laying out some
very obvious truths things that we all
knew to be true that nobody debated 10
years ago why does he not only end up on
Dr Phil as a controversial figure figure
but then need a lawyer to talk to a guy
like me
that's that's the unfortunate part is I
actually came on to help Ray um after he
was removed from his classroom by uh his
school district
um you know just came get dragged out of
class and placed on administrative leave
after he went to a school board meeting
you know just as a private citizen as a
private person on his own time and
decided to speak out against some of
these policies that the school districts
have where they are transing children
behind their parents backs and
implementing all these policies that
really like violate people's right to
their personal beliefs and their deeply
held religious beliefs such as hey
a man is a man a woman is a woman there
are only two Sexes right basic things
like that and because he came and spoke
on his own time he got removed from his
classroom and
I'm here having to help him out and
represent him for his first amendment
case
right so Ray uh little known fact by the
way so you were you were a teacher at
and I have to say were because you are
currently suspended is that correct
well currently I'm actually retired the
you went right from suspension to
retirement so they kind of helped you
out a little bit
well uh the way the process works is
they have an investigation into a
complaint that was made and we can get
into that if you want
but I suspected they just wanted to run
out the clock on the investigation into
my retirement because once I'm retired
then any sort of complaint just becomes
moot
right so you were uh multiple times
twice uh Glendale school teacher of the
year yeah this is the Glendale Unified
School District uh little known fact
actually my the Reuben report has an
interview show started in Glendale my
original Studio was in Glendale over
there so we've probably been to the same
in and out many times
um what what was going on when did you
first start seeing this stuff in the
school let's put it that way
well the the trans the real issue here
in terms of what Disturbed me as as a as
a teacher and as someone who cares
deeply about children
I've worked in the Glendale school
district for 25 years
and my classroom has been highlighted in
local newspapers I've been a master
teacher instructing students from
Pepperdine University from UCLA
and I've served on curriculum review
committees so you know I'm a known
quantity in terms of District
District resources in the last several
years there's been a very slow very
quiet introduction of
of transgender ideology into the
curriculum and into the training
sessions with teachers
and
there has been no Outreach to the
parents no
no transparency
and
this last year at our school site we
were K through five
two
in kindergarten there is a young boy
whose parents are sending him to school
dressed as a girl
and there's also a girl whose parents
are sending her to school dressed as a
boy
and we were informed that we have to use
the preferred pronouns that the family
wants in addressing these students if if
for some reason we would need to as an
upper grade teacher I don't really have
contact with the younger kids
so
so there's this issue of compelled
speech which is what exactly got Dr
Peterson in trouble in Canada
so if we do not comply we will be
disciplined and fired now we all know in
the corporate world you have to do
certain things you don't particularly
like
and you just go along but what Disturbed
me is the other children must comply
with forced speech or they will be
disciplined and expelled and that really
made me very angry as a science teacher
obviously
boys can tell other children are boys or
girls
and the other thing that troubled me
deeply was that you know my students
they really love me they come back they
volunteer they get extra credit for
their High School classes their middle
school classes
and some of my boys came back
telling me that there were girls who
were in the shower room at the middle
school
and looking at them
and
so I inquired are there girls in the a
parent came to me and asked me to
inquire for them are there girls in the
boy's bathroom and the administration
said no
and so uh the parents pushed on it and
it turns out of course that there there
were girls in the boy's bathroom
showering and undressing
um it's just that
they're not called girls they're called
boys because they you know they say I
identify as a boy and if you don't enter
that delusional world
um again you'll be
you'll be um
disciplined so
I mean it's absolutely amazing that
a teenage girl can go into a boy's
bathroom
and restroom and shower room and say I
am male and the other children can do
nothing right we usually think about it
from a high school perspective I think
we usually think about it the other way
because the other way seems more
threatening that it would be a
biological boy in a girl's uh changing
room or locker room or whatever but it's
interesting that it does go both ways
you know there's also obviously the
issue of of just purely at a confusion
level for a parent who is sending their
kid to kindergarten five years old that
they then have to deal with this issue
that no five-year-old is thinking about
I mean I have my kids aren't five yet
but I have nieces and nephews who've
been five years old the idea that a
five-year-old is thinking about this
stuff is crazy uh David I'm curious on
on a legal level uh obviously Ray just
mentioned the compelled speech part of
this so there's a legal issue around
compelled speech but what is there a
legal issue around biology biological
reality as you were talking about before
like what is there an ongoing case right
now that you're involved in are you just
kind of making sure that as Ray is out
there talking to people that he's not
getting into any other trouble with the
district or whatever else there might be
yeah so I think there are two parts to
your question one is you know what is
the sort of ramification of uh denying
biology in the law right and the second
question is what what exactly is going
on with with Rey so also yeah yeah right
now
since Rey's retired we are we're going
to be pursuing a First Amendment case
right because the fact that he got
dragged out of his class he didn't get
to see he didn't get to see his kids
finish the school year right he didn't
get to see his kids graduate which is
like which is you know one of the
biggest things for him as a fifth grade
teacher that's one of the most rewarding
parts of the school year is seeing eyes
kids move on so he got denied all of
that so that's that's the damage right
um those those were the first amendment
violations that caused him you know very
serious harm very serious emotional and
personal harm
um so we're we're raising legal funds
right now for his first amendment
defense to bring that case against the
school district and get him compensated
for what they took away from him uh the
you know the second part of your
question
is you know can they just deny biology
like that and right now sadly in
California uh that's what they're
pushing through you've probably seen the
Crazy Bill that um our Infamous wiener
in San Francisco introduced about taking
away the children from their parents
because they you know they try to uphold
their biological sex
and so in California right now there is
that denial and I think it's it's
crucial to bring these types of cases
and push back against the slow
encroachment of these woke anti-science
ideas
in order not to just protect people's
religious beliefs but this is a
civilizational this is a um absolutely
important existential threat that we
have to fight in the courts and of
course if the legislature helps us out
great but we don't expect that in
California so we have to use the courts
uh to maintain some level of sanity here
yeah it's just incredible we did cover
this story this week out of Cali I mean
unbelievable they literally want to be
able to take your child away if you do
not quote unquote affirm their gender
although as I often say the surgeries
and the chemical castration everything
else is probably the least affirming uh
thing that you could possibly do David
as a teacher can you just talk about the
general state of confusion that's going
on with the kids in terms of I know
you're not a kindergarten teacher but
you mentioned the kindergarten class but
even in fifth grade that this stuff
seems to be talked about all the time
everywhere between the kids teachers Etc
I have no recollection certainly an
elementary school of a teacher ever
bringing up sex or anything like that
yeah I mean I guess my friends and I
joked about silly things or you know we
saw porkies or whatever movie was out
there at the time but like I'm dating
myself but but but that this stuff has
infiltrated virtually everything
culturally for these kids
well you're correct you know when I was
in sixth grade I actually thought that
babies were made by French kissing
only in France only in France so that's
gonna that's gonna date me
I cannot stress I cannot stress
how Insidious this ideology is in
destroying the minds of children and
confusing them and it's meant to do that
this this is not
this is not an innocent let's all uh
accept each other and tolerate each
other because I don't think anyone
um is bothered by the by someone like
Caitlyn Jenner excuse me Caitlyn Jenner
or Deirdre McCloskey or something like
that I don't think that's a particular
issue but this is actually the training
and Recruitment and sexualization of
children and I I do have a visual aid I
do have Show and Tell uh yeah great just
quick just quick
um so aside from lessons that we were
supposed to do which I did not do
um there are there are lots and lots of
books in our library our school library
we're a K through five here is one book
and I I hope the letters are facing the
right way now it says I'm not a girl but
what's important is to look at the
illustration and the text
all right this is this is a book
which is meant
for first and second graders
unbelievable
so you can see that it's a picture book
to be read and at the end of course at
the end what happens is she gets a
haircut and she says she's a boy
so this is integrated into all of the
lessons here is a here's an even uh this
is this one's meant for kindergarten
actually this is called
oh let's see here they she he me and
it's it's it really is a very simple
it's quite beautiful too the artwork is
actually gorgeous
um I mean if I like children's books
so but here is here's some of the
artwork that's inside
and on the back it says pronouns serve
as a familiar starting point for kids
and grown-ups to expand ideas about
gender and celebrate personal expression
um but when you're teaching language to
Children especially to immigrants and
Glendale as you know has many many
immigrants uh language is a tool to be
used for thought to make conceptual
distinctions to understand the world
and later on to engage in
self-reflection and have personal
relationships and find happiness and
productivity in the world
this is sets out to destroy the human
mind
to confuse
the human mind and as I'm sure you both
know in other languages
sometimes they do not have dual pronouns
or they lack articles you know in Korean
there's no articles there's no a there's
no the and in helping people learn to
speak English correctly so that they can
be successful in in the economic world
I mean it's just awful it's just awful
it's it's a world of Make-Believe it's a
it's a world it's teaching um
teaching children a very damaging form
of narcissism
because you know the book um what you
just talked about the indoctrination and
the fact that you have you know so many
immigrant children in that District well
you know I was one of them
back in the day I was one of those
immigrant children
um I was born in Soviet Ukraine I I
started school in the Soviet Union
and when I was starting school
this is exactly the type of
indoctrination that they introduced us
to
um all our children's books all those
things it was all about you know
glorifying communism glorifying great
you know great grandfather Lenin
all those things the hero of the
Revolution and it was exactly those
types of
um
attractive you know drawings and really
really uh insightful and interesting
things for kids that basically
put that worm in our brains from the
very beginning you know to be a member
of the party right like we had books
about uh joining you know the young
Communist Party
right in the the wall and all that and
you know we have little pins that we
used to wear so this is this is using
that same exact Playbook
um to do this to our kids to sexualize
them and to really just uh extinguish
everything we've built on uh in terms of
Western Civilization so you know all
these parallels that's why I think you
have all these Armenian parents standing
up and fighting against it because this
is exactly what they saw when they were
growing up
so you mentioned the Armenian parents so
Glendale has a huge Armenian population
and I'm going to throw to some video we
can we can talk over it we'll just play
it as b-roll of some of the protests uh
that happened in the last couple weeks
weeks where the parents basically were
just out there saying don't sexualize
our kids and then the radical activists
uh were out there demanding sort of all
of the things we've been laying out here
it actually got violent at one point a
couple arrests etc etc what I found
interesting about it uh beyond the
obvious stuff was that the way the media
framed it was that these were pro-lgbt
protesters versus
anti-lgbt protesters except these
parents are just parents who just don't
want State Educators or state employees
talking to their kids about sex and
gender identity and the rest of it so
actually David let me go back to you
quick on this what can the parents do
legally at this point if California is
as crazy as we all seem to think and as
you guys probably know I fled California
and a half ago partly because I knew
this stuff was coming what can a parent
who has a kid at a public school that is
going through all of this that does not
have a teacher like Ray who's doing the
right thing but is in a class third
grade class fourth grade class that's
being indoctrinated does that parent
have any legal recourse absolutely
um you know there's a there's a long
history precedent from the Supreme from
our Supreme Court that uh parents have
the right to dictate the values that
their children are inculcated with so
you know I think we can use that as a
weapon long term but on
on a day-to-day basis sort of the um
the simple stuff is talk to your talk to
your children make sure you have a very
strong relationship
um get copious notes of what's going on
in their school in their classroom uh do
foyer requests right public records
request and don't give up because these
school districts are very sneaky and
they're very evasive in terms of
producing relevant documents
if you need to and this is important you
know once you've collected enough
information talk to a lawyer because
there are there are
vulnerabilities right this is these laws
in California
um they're sort of like the Death Star
but
there is a vulnerability there is that
there's always a way to blow up a death
star exactly so you know we have ways
um I think I'm not I'm not ready to
disclose them yet because the other side
is obviously listening but they exist
and we're working on it so
collect collect as much evidence as you
can and find a lawyer you know if not me
they're they're a handful of lawyers uh
in California who are very good at this
and who are dedicated to this fight so
that's that's what I would say is get
the evidence make sure you uh you know
get on the school tell them you're not
okay with it and then talk to a lawyer
Ray what kind of support are you getting
I'm guessing mostly unfortunately on the
DL from other teachers and and staff
members you know administrative staff
that sort of thing and also from parents
because we know one of the main issues
here is that everyone's afraid of
getting canceled these days so they're
probably afraid of now being seen out at
the local restaurant with you
well
well in in terms of in terms of Glendale
as you know it is fairly conservative as
a community
and I can say that at my school site
or my former School site
at least two-thirds of the staff
completely reject this
uh transgender ideology
uh the people that I work with they were
completely against it they understood
clearly what was going on and they just
avoided it as much as possible
unfortunately not a single one of them
has said anything and I understand I
don't blame them because they have
children they have spouses
now the same thing with the parents many
of the parents at my school My Views are
My Views about a lot of issues
um
I I've never been quote unquote
politically correct and my parents know
that and parents
often request me specifically for that I
mean over the years
so the parents have been fantastic
the the parents uh I mean I've always
had a very good loving relationship with
all my parents because my goal as a
teacher is to help their students to
help their student learn to develop
their mind
and to
you know to be a good teacher you have
to be able to reach a student's mind
where they are whether Consciousness is
and help them build a bridge
and
my focus has always been the students
and so I I have a fantastic rep so the
parents are behind me but unfortunately
again you know they usually have
businesses and they're terrified of of
being mobbed of being doxed which I was
um and
and losing their business so
everybody basically tries to stay under
the radar
um
I'm gonna let David finish with another
promotion of the of the uh crowdfunding
to help you guys out but uh Ray just one
or two more for you first off do you
want to be retired now I mean we do have
a lot of great teaching place a lot of a
lot of good a lot of great places of
teaching also known as schools here in
Florida where uh you would be welcomed
obviously well you know I I would have
continued working here for a few more
years except I knew I just couldn't
stomach it so no my my career as a
teacher is not over the it's just a
matter of where the next step is in
terms of of finding a position to be
productive in the world okay I have one
more question for you then which is was
it when I was going through my notes
this morning uh one of my guys pointed
out you happen to be gay uh I would say
happen to be because uh I happen to be
gay it is what it is it's not that
interesting actually but people find it
interesting when having this specific
conversation
um I didn't know that about you until 10
minutes before we started but does that
play a role in this somehow or change
the Optics of it somehow or give you
Insight somehow into what your feelings
are around all this
well my first gay March was in 1980
you know so 40 over 40 years ago and
um
I've always been openly gay my parents
know that my colleagues know that and I
think it does I think it frightens the
school district in particular because I
know exactly what they're doing just
like the left used gay Americans as a
tool
they uh to try to divide Americans they
are now doing this with the transgender
issue the other thing is that the
parents are not anti-gay at all and that
is how the left wants to keep painting
them instead of taking them seriously
you know at this Riot that I was there I
was down there watching everything the
other side was antifa and the pr and a
few proud boys he's had helmets they had
their faces covered uh one of the antifo
characters pulled out a knife and tried
to stab one of the Armenian fathers and
and the he was arrested it turns out
guess what he's a child molester okay
he's been arrested for sexual activity
with a 14 year old girl so the real
division was antifa proud boys and
you know the alphabet suit people the
crazy people right the LGBT there is no
such people there is no such Community
uh you know I'm a gay man I'm not a
lesbian I'm not transgender right it's
made up it's just made up uh in order to
to make a box for to try to gain
political votes uh and the issue of
homosexuality has nothing nothing to do
with transgenderism at all and it's just
a way of them trying to ride on our
backs so as a gay man and I think this
is part of the reason why I was removed
from my classroom so quickly because
it's one thing you know to have a
straight guy you know they can easily
just call him a bigot but they can't do
that with me
so I think it's and I think it's more
important that more and more gay
Americans speak up
in particular and go to the front of the
line with this and saying no sexualizing
children is wrong
um
so I do think so I do think it is
important and I do think it you know I
haven't I actually haven't talked to my
lawyer about this but I do think that my
district in in removing me
violated the anti-discrimination laws of
California I think it was targeted
because I was gay
no this thing about not fitting into the
intersectional calculator in in the way
that they want probably does lend to
something related uh to that for sure uh
David if you have any other final
thoughts and then I want you to promote
the the crowdfunding so that we can
raise some funds for you guys because
obviously this is a worthwhile cause and
of course we'll put the link down below
thank you beautiful thanks Dave yeah so
we're on Gibson go uh because GoFundMe
is run by commies uh so again gifts and
go you know just go on the website you
just search for Ray Shelton search under
Ray's name and you'll find our first
amendment legal defense fund so please
yeah anything you can do to contribute
uh we both Ray and I really appreciate
it
yes we really do it's really really
important because this isn't about me
it's about me I'm it's about trying to
help change our culture at least a
little bit into the right direction and
it's about protecting children that's
really what it's about
and Ray if this was a Hollywood show
this is where I would say now stay we're
going to do another show that's going to
be much more controversial and we'd get
you into a lot of trouble but this is
the internet we do things a little bit
differently uh I thank you guys for your
time and if I can help out in any other
way please don't hesitate to ask
thank you so much for having uh having
us I I God bless you and um
thank you so much yeah absolutely thanks
Dave if you're looking for more honest
and thoughtful conversations about
politics instead of mindless dribble
check out our politics playlist and if
you want to watch full interviews on a
variety of topics watch our full episode
playlist all right over here and to get
notified of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
Bell